welcome to this meeting of baber
District Council cabinet I'm councilor
John Ward leader of baby District
Council and I'll be chairing this
meeting
may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
and finally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
so please give members make sure they
are logged in and ready to use the app
I'd like to write everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except whether our confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use
those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'll now move to the agenda item one
apologies for absence
thank you
item two to receive Declarations of
pecunery other registrable or
non-registerable interests by members
are there any to declare
councilor Osborne
I live in a report that there will be
discussion around the CA and then I will
have to declare an interest thank you
item three paper VCA 2231 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 3rd
of October 2022
so just for completeness I'll go through
um this is using page numbering in in
the gender pack page five anyone
Page Six
page seven
page eight
and finally page nine
so if there are no comments
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
may have a proposal and second to please
councilor malvisi propose may I have a
secondary
Council Osborne
and I'll now ask the governor's officer
to conduct the vote
councilor Arthur how is he
thank you chair that is uh six votes
four and one abstention thank you
right the next item is item four
questions by councilors none received
item six matters referred by the
overview in scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees then
thank you item seven forthcoming
decisions list
cabinet members are there any comments
or questions about forthcoming decisions
list
nope
thank you
item seven
paper BCA 2232 general fund Financial
monitoring
2022-23 Quarter Two
I'd like to invite the cabinet member
for finance assets and Investments to
introduce the report
councilor Busby over to you
Mike oh it's over here
I think you can probably hear me anyway
um okay well I think we start off by
saying what a difference 12 months makes
back at this time last year we were
looking at an underspend
uh we were optimistic inflation was
about
two percent something like that
and as a result we decided to set a
tight budget so there's little or no
slack in the budget had me realize what
we were about to face I think we would
have been a bit more cautious
we know that inflation has soared
when and we're now forecasting about 700
000 pounds over budget which is largely
due to the increase in staff costs we
budgeted for about two percent it looks
more like eight percent
and other things such as we've there's
been a slight delay in the uh Endeavor
house move in terms of shuffling space
around Etc
so those are the two main reasons why
the general fund
is not looking particularly healthy at
the moment
I want to ask questions on that on the
general fund I can take those now or I
can go on to Capital and you can ask
questions at the end of it okay
capitalism
so
putting something down here and I can't
work out my own writing
we always we all know that we never
spend all that we budget for on on
Capital items and this year's no
exception
um
we've spent
just under a million pounds so far
um
but we're forecasting that that will
arise to
at 10 million
by the end of the year so
if you add in a carry forward of 13.4
million it's 400 000 pounds less than
budgeted
I have one or two questions really that
would not be dealt with in this meeting
about what should be capital and what
shouldn't be I just wonder whether
the brown bins should be treated as
capital or not it doesn't seem much like
a capital item to me but anyway
so there we go I jet capital
follows a normal Trend slow initial
spend picks up towards the end of the
year but we have a big carry forward
and one thing we will be washing rushing
to do with capital spend is to is to
borrow to enable us to do it and
then good return on the project
so I'm happy to take questions on the
general fund
thank you councilor Busby so you're
proposing may have a second to please
come from RVC thank you
members of the cabinet does anyone have
any questions for Council Busby
councilman crawl
this is more of a general question
because obviously we're well into the
budget process now but I just wanted to
ask Dave if uh if there's any sort of um
late change that we might expect and we
do make have made in the past
regular jokes about rabbits being pulled
out of hats
I wouldn't expect a massive rabbit but
is there a sort of a small little bunny
in there somewhere just something that
might mitigate the situation a little
foreign
ly uh Tommy Cooper does not work in the
finance team
um so there is certainly for this year
I think it would be expecting something
unusual to get
a big
rabbit that comes over the hat to save
us this year
as for next year we're still trying to
work with numbers crunch the numbers
but there are such big items that
weren't still not certain of you I mean
the government won't let us know what
the settlement's going to be there's
business rates I mean there's there's
millions of pounds that are still up for
grabs so we'll have to wait and see for
those
any other questions
Council Rossi
it's one about um
the corporate resources figure
in the appendix
um the last
reason given is budgeted variance in
management factor sorry vacancy did I
say variance vacancy vacancy management
factor of half a million pounds is
included within corporate resources
this offsets forecast vacancy under
spends in all services can somebody just
explain that to me
each year as you know we
budget to be under spent on
staff in terms of we don't feel
vacancies as as quickly as perhaps we
could have done or we hold the vacancy
what we've done is we hold that budget
for the whole Council under corporate
resources
okay so there's all the savings on
delayed
staff vacancies comes under corporate
resources
the actuals go under the the teams
so there's unfortunately you look at the
budget in one team I.E corporate
resources but you see the the actual you
know the various teams which you can see
um it lists there some of the
costs that have occurred
in the teams
and some of the savings that have
occurred in the teams as well
sorry does that to get understand that
um no not really
um I'm still not quite clear why we've
got an extra half a million pounds in
there the only reason surely for that
could be that we had budgeted to
him and we've ended up having them in
employment is that right
it's the opposite way around
yes it's we we've got a vacancy so we've
budgeted to
take fill the vacancy but we delay doing
so and we estimate that it's three
months approximately
is the usual delay and therefore we
understand on our staff costs because we
don't fill the vacancy as quick as we
could
I still won't quite get it but I'm sure
Rebecca could you provide further
clarification please for councilor Artie
thank you yes certainly so um
Council Busby's correct so the budget
for the transitional vacancy sits within
corporate resources in effect that's a
negative negative budget it shows us 500
000 income
but during the year when the vacancies
happen the underspends go against the
different services so the under spends
are in there in the variants but they're
in the other in the other services so
there's nothing against the 500 000
negative budget within corporate
resources
which makes it look a bit like an
overspend
so it makes it look like an overspend
but it's not but it's not yet
but I think we'll try and smooth that
out for next year's but to observant
it doesn't leave this kind of an
explanation
are there any other questions
if not we can move into debate if anyone
wants to uh to comment and debate um I'd
just like to open up by saying that that
the position we've got here at quarter
two is actually a 90 000 pound
Improvement on on the quarter one
forecast so um uh it is a better picture
um
yeah
whether we can expect that to change
through quarter three and through to the
out turn or not um I don't know but the
important thing is that
with our budget surplus last year and we
put half a million pounds into the
inflationary pressures Reserve we're
able to draw on that to help us through
this this situation we've got here which
um
was a
sensible piece of foresight really
in terms of being able to smooth out
things like that and also of course
we've got our strategic priorities
reserve and we can dip into that so
um Marley is the reserves is not
something you want to to regularly rely
on it is nonetheless we we have got
healthy reserves and we've been able to
use them to
um to um deal with this forecast
overspend
does anyone else wish to say anything
I'll just say that you can't keep
dipping into your reserves because
they're a finite number unless you can
keep topping them up
once they've gone they've gone I know
any further comments from anyone
in which case then
we will move to the vote papers being
proposed and seconded so we will now go
to the vote please
thank you chair the voters in progress
that is seven votes fall and that's
unanimous yeah
Right Moving on then item nine paper BCA
2233 the HRA Financial monitoring for 22
to 23
um Quarter Two again I'd like to invite
the cabinet member for finance assets
and Investments to introduce the report
Council Busby
okay you can almost repeat what I said
in the first question really uh it's
the housing revenue account has been hit
by similar issues really
we were budgeting for a 500 000 pound
Surplus it now looks as though it's
going to be
three hundred thousand pounds overspend
so we're 800 000 pounds worse off
roughly at least 825 there
that's despite the fact that rents have
increased by one percent uh
giving us an extra quarter of a million
it's on the cost side where the problems
occur on housing management
Building Services and the repairs and
maintenance
where we've we've seen our own costs
increase we've had to also employ
contractors and Consultants
all of which have made
budgets blown out of the water quite
frankly
and that does not look as though it's
going to change for next year we've got
a lot of work to do on the housing
front and I suspect that we might be
over next year on that as well
for on the capital side
of the budget we spent six million we've
got a further eight that we anticipate
spending which will leave 9 million to
carry forward so again we although we
budget quite High numbers we're very
rare that we would expect to spend all
of it
I think we know the projects that have
that are progressing certainly the
headquarters at Hadley is progressing
nicely
um
the issues we have some issues in
Sudbury which will take some time to
sort out whether that budget that's been
in Marked for Sudbury gets spent next
year or not I don't know we'll have to
see but it'll be carried forward
anyway
so I happy to propose the
recommendations if I can have a second
Castle Roswell a second
thank you for that councilor Busby are
there any questions anyone
kasarathi
yeah similar to before really just
picking out half a million pounds here
um and that's on repairs and maintenance
and is detailed as being overspend on
the use of subcontractors to support the
trades team
a backlog of void and responsive jobs
built up as a result of covid
um I think I seem to remember that last
year we had a very similar thing and
during covid we had a love
sort of jobs out it's it's been about 12
months now since the sort of the
relaxation if you like of covert
restrictions
um and so we're I mean are we still
catching up have we caught up
um or is this going to continue and I
mean there's obviously the issue that um
councilor Osborne might answer which is
the continued use of contractors because
our own teams can't complete the work
I think in order to to add to that
um the position we've got a quarter two
is three hundred thousand pounds worse
than it was a quarter one so
uh stabilizing as well for the rest of
the year
yeah thank you Mr chairman I think what
what you've done in the past
he said that we've been underestimating
the budget for our repairs and
maintenance and with all the
transformation work that's currently
being taken place it will become more
realistic budget if you compare us to
other authorities although we're not on
the lowest charge in we do tend to
underestimate on the cost each of per
house within the within the two
districts
um I think the transformation work
that's being done will look at all this
and it will become more of a reality of
where we actually are but I think to
answer your concern
[Music]
um
Clive it's it's a case of I'm sure it's
a case that we've been underestimating
in the budget in regards to the
contractors I'll go to Deborah if I may
because it's going to be necessary to
con to use contractors and continue to
use contractors contractors if we want
to get to the situation where we need to
be to assure that our tenants are
getting the right level of service but
if I could come to our corporate manager
for sorry our director for housing thank
you
thank you so so
um yes we will be continuing to use
contractors for some time yet because we
do have a backlog of repairs and we need
to get to a steady state we're doing a
number of things to improve the
situation as members will be aware we're
going through a diagnostic exercise
which will then form our transformation
plan which is likely to take
um
18 months to two years to fully
implement
we've also put in the budget for next
year
um a sum of money to carry out a
comprehensive stock condition survey so
we have been carrying out stock
condition surveys but we want to enhance
that further
and what that will allow us to do is
feed the data into our 30-year business
plan which will then help us
plan our component replacement program
over the next 30 Years that will reduce
our spend on repairs and maintenance
because it will mean we're taking a
planned approach rather than a reactive
approach
thank you Deborah councilor arthi
well it's just in response to all of
that really so I'm still not absolutely
clear I think the point of the question
was is this because we're still playing
catch-up
or is this a reflection of the fact that
costs have increased and moving forward
we're going to be looking at these
increased figures
yes and yes
yes it isn't because of we are catching
up I mean two things really one is as I
said because of covid but also
resourcing we've had a problem getting
getting the kind of resources with this
as you're aware in the construction
sector materials some materials are in
short supply therefore it's you can't
operate as an in an efficient way as you
would like necessarily
um so I would I think we're going to see
these this level of costs for the next
two or three years until we can catch up
unfortunately
but who knows
um we could be entering a
a reduction in house demand or house
Supply next year the builders might cut
back because of the housing market and
we might find that we've got plenty of
resource that we can
tap into
but I think it's going to be a tough
couple of years we can't keep doing that
because there's only a finite amount of
budget
Council was warn you ought to say
something yeah thank you Mr chairman
yeah I think Council Arthur It's a
combination of the two really
and I have to be perfectly up front it's
going to get worse before it gets better
but there is going to be light at the
end of the tunnel and as I've just
alluded to on the transformation work we
will at least know where we're going and
how we're going to get there and the
cost of getting there which is very
critical to the whole thing
thank you
are there any other questions
if not we'll move into debate does
anyone wish to say anything about the
HRA course to position
hasn't already been covered in the
questions
Council Osborne
thank you if no members are either
coming in on the debate I would like to
say that obviously there are as
um David has already alluded to there
are so many challenges coming forward
for our housing team and they work under
really hard in motive
challenging circumstances so I think
it's important that members support all
the work that they do
in moving things forward thank you Mr
chairman
I think Castle Osborne
if no one else has anything they wish to
say then I'll move to the vote on this
item
maybe conduct the electronic vote please
thank you
that vote design progress members
that is seven votes four that's
unanimous chair thank you
item nine paper BCA 2234 course 2
performance report for 2022-23 I'd like
to invite the cabinet member for
customers digital transformation and
Improvement to introduce the report
councilor McCraw
thank you very much chair you have to
excuse me I have a number of papers to
look at this is um the quarter two
performance and the paper just described
um it provides a selection of
performance highlights for each of the
council's strategy
and it's intended to give baber members
an opportunity to consider our
achievements for quarter 2 22-23 at this
meeting I would stress of course that
this is Quarter Two we're now at the end
of quarter three approaching quarter
four so this is historical information
rather than myself go through each item
I'm going to ask of each Cabinet member
uh could pick out an item from their
portfolio starting off with the economy
portfolio and then through the others I
wonder if that would be okay councilor
Ward
that would be perfect yes we can do that
so I will start then thank you very much
um well for me there are two things
firstly it's good to see that the
innovate local scheme
um at the southern Hadley markets is is
continuing and that we've got nine new
businesses supported in this period
um
it's it's something which
um I I think uh it was a great success
we probably didn't realize how good how
successful it was going to be so I'm
very pleased at that the other thing I
just wanted to point out um although at
this point of course too so 60
businesses nominated across nine
categories for the Innovation Awards
those Innovation Awards have now taken
place and they were a resounding success
it was um an excellent event so um two
two high points in in the economy
portfolio
thank you
councilor malvisi for the environment do
you have a highlight you'd like to point
out
thank you councilor mcroll
um
well our garden waste of
subscribers continue to increase
um this quarter we saw 51 join the
scheme rising to so the total number of
17
000 which is is good the fly-tipping
incidents
um 98 of them are cleared in 48 hours
um when the total number is 90
individuals decided to dump their waste
on public land these figures do not
reflect what gets dumped on private land
because we're not responsible for that
for clearing that
um
food businesses in baber
88 of them have got a good hygiene
rating of five
but where my old Headmaster would be
saying to me we need to try harder is
the recycling collected figures
we're still dealing with a 12-month
rolling average of about 15.8 percent
that means that 15.8 percent of what we
have collected in order to recycle was
contaminated
and therefore had to go to incineration
so we do need to try harder to increase
or decrease that figure and increase the
amount that recycle it that's available
thank you very much councilman vesi and
for the customer's portfolio I think the
point I'd highlight from the overall
report is the the level of calls that
we've received in that quarter we've
received an average of 556 calls per day
and a total of 506 visits to the
customer access points the Caps within
Hadley shotley and Sudbury
there was a 12 reduction in calls per
day from quarter one so quarter one was
even busier the total visit and total
visits to the Caps decreased by 26 due
to the end of the council tax rebate
initiative point I'm making here is that
the the level the workload which is
provided by all the portfolios in the
council because customers on the phone
calls will be talking about every single
thing that's on
see there's a lot on everybody's mind
quota 2 was not as busy as quarter one
but it was if anything uh still a very
high level of cause
if we move on I have communities next
but I don't think we have our um
communities portfolio holder here so I
shall do that one for the stuff and I
thought the point that I noted and I
know that this is a matter that's
concerned many members of the public is
ASB
um in the quarter a total of 11 new
anti-social Behavior cases were
discussed at the ASB partnership panel
and further 29 lower risk ASB
we dealt with by officers ASB is not a
subject that's being
um if we move on then to well-being
um who was the best person to speak on
the subject of well-being as a portfolio
holder between Council McLaren as well
councilman McLaren as well in that case
I thought it was important to point out
that there were 36
722 households were supported with the
council tax energy rebate under the
mandatory and the discretionary schemes
and almost 5 million pounds was spent
and distributed and I think we all
understand how important that money was
for our communities and our residents
councilor Osborne I now bring us to
housing if you have any points you'd
like to bring up from there
thank you very much
um as well as the development of an
excellent tenants engagement policy
which I know is quarter three but I
can't help mentioning it because it is
an excellent excellent policy
we also approved an empty homes policy
in the in quarter two and we all know
that if we can bring empty homes back in
to use it helps reduce the number of
homeless people and also helps to reduce
the number of people on the housing
register if I could just quote some
figures uh the number of empty homes
inspected was in Babel six this is the
quarter two number of owners engaged
with 122
number of Grants offered just one a
number of Grants awarded is zero so we
we need to look at that and long-term
empty sport back into use is 26 and
empty homes letters sent
um asking people to come forward was 110
so I'm sure members will agree with me
they are excellent figures and is
showing that the empty homes policy is
actually working
and when I attended the last Suffolk
housing board I know that some of the
other Suffolk authorities are going to
use that as an Exemplar as well for them
to to adopt so excellent work to all
concerned
you very much Jen the final item is on
the health of the organization which I
don't think falls upon any particular
portfolio holder and I'm not going to
ask the chief executive to comment on it
but I did note that our average number
of days of sickness may have increased
marginally from the previous quarter
from 1.8 to 1.8 from 1.64 but the total
number of days lost to six has actually
decreased and the top two reasons for
absence are still covid-19 and mental
health and I think it's important that
we keep an eye on that the final one
though I think is important is that our
reach for Facebook
is eighty four thousand two hundred and
forty five that's the number of unique
users who had any content from our
Facebook page or about the page
um in on their screens and I just point
out that that's not very far short of
our population
I think is interesting
it's not far short is my point
proportionately it's about on that level
what I was going to suggest is if
anybody has any questions on the content
of the performance of the quarter two
that they asked them now to the relevant
Cabinet member and we'll see where we go
from there
thank you councilman crawl so
are there any questions
Council arthi
yes
so a little bit like the previous paper
which was an out turn report there's
nothing we can do to change what's
already happened
but
the the thing that I always mention
um and have done for quite some time
so I think you know where I'm going
is in the customers section
um and it's on page 44 and it's about
the
um waiting time for people calling us
and the abandoned rate
so
there are reasons given in here and
we've been given reasons before
um as to why this this could be the case
does it now mean that the people that we
were short of have now been trained up
we will see an improvement in these
figures either next quarter or by the
end of the year
Castle mccral
yes thank you I mean effectively yes and
what's more I can stay say yes with some
confidence
um
we know that we've had this average
handling time of course uh Rising
we know why that is the workload I've
referred to in the report itself and the
last two quarters has been exceptionally
High
we have had a lot of stuff seconded
we've trained new stuff I've mentioned
before in briefings that it takes
roughly 12 weeks to train a new member
of the call center staff in just one
particular part of it and obviously as
they gain more experience and they gain
more confidence during the training
process this takes away the more
experienced call handlers but I return
to this point that everything that the
call center deals with is stuff that
people have concerns about from across
the entire council's operation and when
we have stresses across in society and
in the council area in particular
portfolios we know where those stresses
lie and I don't want to go into the
detail of those but I'd ask members to
consider that the workload that comes
through the call center is that
generated by all our portfolios it is
not the creation it is the it is the
result we have to handle it now how's
the improving well the most recent
figures which date I think into the
middle of last months that's November
show a distinct full the staff are
becoming more confident and I think we
can expect figures of below four minutes
and getting down to three minutes I I
wouldn't like to pin it down exactly I
would point out that there are days in
every month in every quarter where we
achieve being incredibly
um
ambitious Target of one minute 45
seconds there are several days in every
month it's just that there are days
where a single call can take a great
deal longer
I wish I could give you a stronger
answer than that the point is the trend
is going in the right direction I hope
that answers your question councilor
Arthur
Council Oswald
thank you Mr chairman I see for the
environment that the internet of lie
took in going back to
fly to Tiffin in particular now I know
during Quarter Two we had a day event in
an air specific area in cornard where we
were going to introduce some pilot
schemes on helping to reduce the level
of fly tipping on our developments I was
just wondering how they're panning out
and are we planning to move them into
other areas Within baber
thank you councilor Osborne um
Council my visual or I think
the operations yeah
okay Mark are you able to provide an
update I'm afraid I don't have that
information but I will go away and get
it thank you
we'll have to report back on that
Council Oswald
any other questions
no okay then well this um paper is is
for noting only so there is there is no
vote but um as usual it's got some uh
great information in it and it's very
easy to understand possibly you got a
quick question then
we're talking about the
when I had a text message sent to me
which was blank blank blank canceled
been trying to talk to them for two
weeks emailed nearly every day they
won't respond neither architect or us
can get hold of them they're around
I mean effectively if any of these
situations arises and if any member
becomes aware of such a poor response
could they let myself
Sam
and Sarah know about them we'll
investigate and we have done in the past
and in fact we've been managed to
resolve what the situation has been in
some cases it's just been a breakdown in
Communications because what the
what somebody thinks they're sending
money has not been going to the right
place but if we don't know about it we
can't deal with it
um I just found some further information
that might actually help on on the
subject of of how the the new staff are
developing I'm afraid I I missed the
bottom part of my notice I apologize to
my uh my team there
um the the staff
um most recent figure for November um
for call waiting was three minutes ten
the abandonment rate has been reduced
further and is down to from an earlier
figure of 23 to 16 and we expect that to
be decreasing as the team become fully
trained we're also recruiting three
Apprentice positions as we're trialling
different initiatives and the idea is to
develop
um
skill set that can be used for more
things than just customer services I
think you
that as I say anything like that that
comes up councilor Busby please let me
or the team know and we will investigate
I mean no no mean write down to the
detail I phoned people myself and I
would expect the team would follow up as
well
thank you that councilman crawl and and
the point is that uh these things do
happen from time to time it's
unfortunate but um that's what castles
are there for members of the public need
to get in in touch with their local
councilor who can pick up and resolve
these issues on their behalf
okay then
if everyone's happy we'll we'll move on
um thank you for that councilman crawl
item 10 paper BCA 2235 the cost of
living crisis five-point action plan
progress report at Phase One and the
phase two action plan in the absence of
Castle McLaren councilor Osborne has
kindly volunteered to introduce this
report councilor Osborne
I'm volunteering but there you go at the
initial launch of the cost of living
crisis report it was seen as ambitious
and lacking detail and cabinet members
were unsure whether the plan was robust
enough to meet the needs of our
residents and requested to be kept
informed of the plan's progress
front of you today is a comprehensive
report that gives context and background
as to the change in landscape of the
cost of living crisis
summary of the work undertaken over the
last six months against the five-point
action plan phase one which was agreed
by baber cabinet in June 2022.
the phase two action plan for the next
six months through the winter into
spring recognizing the need for winter
preparedness and the required
flexibility to enable the council to
respond to emerging needs in this
fast-moving environment
as agreed in the recommendation 3.2 from
the 8th of June 22 cabinet
however behind this report has been a
lot of good teamwork and commitment and
the dynamic has changed which I think
needs to be noted publicly today
the needs and and cries we envisage has
become the reality and for the
foreseeable future they are going to be
constantly moving goal posts
the project has expanded beyond the
remit of the community's directorate and
internal stakeholder group is in place
overseeing and monitoring the direction
of the project
our Target population now includes staff
as well as residents
many of the defined objectives cannot be
met by any one organization so our
relationship with the voluntary
health and other public sector
organizations is essential to
implementation
our external Partners in Leisure are
providing some excellent work in
relation to warm spaces
social prescribing dementia support
health and well-being activities for
many different age groups
we welcome the appointment of the cost
of living coordinator Liza Dale who
reports to Sam Lake Eliza is working
very hard with all our partners to
ensure good outcomes and to achieve our
main objectives and that is not an easy
task
in conclusion I wish to thank Dai
Robinson and Vicki morsley the internal
stakeholder group and the community's
locality teams for all their hard work
to achieve so much in the short space of
time and all those who contributed and
wrote the report in front of you today
members I would like to draw your
attention to item three the
recommendations which is to review and
note the content of phase one cost of
living five-point action plan dashboard
report in appendix one and 3.2 to note
the focus of the phase two Cost of
Living Action Plan at appendix 2. both
papers are for noting and no decision is
required and officer Sam Lake and Vicki
Mosley are here to take questions thank
you very much members and chairman
thank you Council Osborne may I have a
second to please
customer VC
members of the cabinet does anyone have
any questions
Council Osborne
thank you very much to officers I
apologize if I've missed this I have
looked at the action plan and I've
looked at the report so if I've missed
it I do apologize but you refer to
strong working with Partners to achieve
the outcomes outlined in the action plan
have you been working with town and
Parish councils because I know for
example in Sudbury there's a lot of work
going on they've set up I think the Town
Council have set up similar to a food
bank there for example which is working
really well and I'm just concerned that
we'll have duplication where town and
parishes are working in isolation we are
working in isolation and it's much
better to work together to get results
so are we working and talking to our
town and Parish councils
thank you for the question counselor yes
we are so every time we have any updates
or any information that we can share or
news or information around potential
funding streams to create and develop
things like warm spaces then we've been
liaising directly with our town parish
councils and also last month and the
month before I attended a selk forum
meeting as well where I just explained
the roles of the communities team but
also the work that we've done on cost of
living so we've also shared it that way
in that presentation also was then
circulated toward town and Parish
councils where we have information also
coming for that we've created in terms
of Flyers whether that's crazy that
we've created or they've been created by
the County Council which basically links
up all of our web pages and the various
government support pools the local
support around elwest for example we've
also been sharing that with our um
parish councils and as
as it was just in terms of your
introductions the locality officers have
also been working closely with with
parish councils as well so keeping their
ears to the ground where there's a need
or whether where a particular group may
require additional funding to enhance or
extend their their Community programs to
become warm spaces then we've also been
making sure that they're Linked In with
our various grants teams as well so we
are working
thank you councilor malvisi
I'm glad to hear that
here that this chairman
of council the other evening I had a
counselor and well several councilors
querying a communication that we'd
received from and I can't remember
specifically but it was a community
interest company
providing warm spaces and it came from
baber
and we had no prior knowledge didn't
know what they were talking about didn't
know where they were going
um and I was left looking pretty stupid
so if at all possible after this meeting
could we have two words
thank you councilman obviously any other
questions
it's not really a question I don't think
but it's kind of a question and that's
to support what councilor Osborne asked
us a question really about working in
Partnership
um
I'm specifically talking about town and
Parish councils but in the report and
I've just gone off the page but I think
it's the top item
for our refresh is working in
Partnership because in all honesty on
our
there isn't a great deal that we can
achieve the point is that we've got a
role to play working with others
to jointly do something to help
so it's not really a question I'm sorry
no no that was um straight into debate
but it doesn't matter I'll be flexible
councilman girl actually on a similar
point and and just as an observation in
my own Community I know of two
organizations that are organizing warm
spaces and a third one that has been
doing a coffee Caravan every Wednesday
for two hours every Wednesday of free
coffee and biscuits and it's actually a
huge success it's getting this is before
the matter of warm spaces came up but
it's ongoing and it's attracting over 30
people every week but two other one is a
community interest company two other
organizations have set up their own
schemes and they may not have actually
had any contact with us on this they're
just going ahead and doing it
independently I've offered fantastic
funding myself through my localities
budget and that would be
Church which is doing exactly the same
thing so it's not always going to be
tied together a lot of community
organizations
um go their own way and and they don't
get in touch with us and it's trying to
keep track of it there's a lot of good
will out there a lot of people are
coming to the same conclusion so I can
see where the difficulty might have
Arisen but I don't know if it's
necessarily something that they would
inform us of
the thought
thank you councilman cruel councilman
visi
education traffic is baber then surely
they should come to their District
councils first
that are responsible for that Ward and
say these people are going to be working
we'll engage with them we'll meet with
them
but when something lands on the doormat
you're left yes and and you're as a
district councilor you're left with no
information you can't respond you can't
update you can't inform
okay
thank you councilor Osborne are we in
debate Mr
gently
um I absolutely agree you know working
in partnership with all the other
partners is key to the success of the
action plan and without them we just
will not achieve it I think babe are a
leading in the field in this one and
it's great that we've taken the
incentive that we're moving forward on
this
I do hope that the health providers
and also Suffolk County Council are
coming forward as well and helping both
financially and with resources as well
and because it's not just down to Bay
but it's very commendable that we're
taking the lead on this but we also need
them to work with us if it's going to be
deliverable so I do hope that they are
coming forward my experience in the past
is that the health providers for example
a little bit slow income especially
where it's all about prevention they're
more about cure at the moment and
prevention so hopefully they start to
think around that but also
um Suffolk County Council as well so do
we have any indication as to the support
we're getting from them at the moment
sorry I've now gone back into a question
but it's just triggered something in my
mind thank you
uh certainly I agree um and in terms of
the County Council they have provided
support
[Music]
is that any better yeah I can hear
myself better as well
um yeah so with regard to sort of
funding some of the schemes we are we we
do work closely with Suffolk County
Council as part of the collective
communities board where there's uh
funding that does come down to the
districts as a result of the work that
we do there and certainly a lot of the
support we provide you in terms of warm
spaces so far has been with funding
that's come from the the County Council
we've also in terms of want to say we
babers also contributed to that fund as
well so it's a kind of a co-production
of that warm spaces
um grant funding process in terms of our
Health Partners they tend to be more
specific around certain types of
projects so they will um which will
support things which not directly around
warm warm spaces necessarily but we'll
be on programs that support the
well-being of our communities and we do
and we work in partnership with them
with regards to those types of
activities so you're absolutely right we
we do work very closely with those
Partners to ensure that we provide a
sort of a well-rounded holistic program
of support not just
signposting to other types of financial
support which is what we do with regards
to those government schemes
thank you Vicky any other questions or
comments
if not I'd like to finish with a quick
question it's probably best directed to
councilor Osborne the discretionary
housing payments which we administer
through the shared revenues partnership
do we have any feelers to
what the numbers were the previous year
we've got numbers so far here for both
labor and Midsouth for
this situation now but um as part of
this cost of living report but do we
know what how that compares with
previous years and also
um is there a cap on the funds that we
distribute
I've got the figures I I attended the
shared Revenue partnership meet on the
23rd of November so this is the latest
report that I've got And in regards to
the discretionary housing payments I
haven't got a comparison for last year I
didn't bring that report with me so I
apologize
um but the the grant itself was 86
572. we've paid out
33 580 pounds committed is
8522 so remaining is forty four thousand
four hundred and sixty nine so the
percentage if we've awarded is
48.63 and there's a lot of work going on
behind the scenes to ensure that we
deliver basically award 100 because
there's a demand there's got to be a
demand out there for it and I'm sure
with the next report that we get from
the shared Revenue partnership that
would have increased that percentage
awarded will have increased considerably
I don't know if that answers your
question with regards to a cat what we
don't spend unfortunately has to go back
um so it's it's imperative that with
everything that's going on and the cost
of living and the eating crisis and
everything else you know we need to
spend 100 of that Grant
and there's a lot of work going on
behind the scenes to make sure that that
happens thank you Council Osborne that
answers it perfectly thank you
okay everyone if um they're no further
questions or comments
um as Council Osborne said this this is
just a review and note the the paper so
there is no vote
there is a vote
not on this one
oh well I've just been informed there is
a vote but
this this is the cost of living paper
it's not in my notes
okay so there's a verse on this paper
I apologize for the confusion but the
vote stand progress
sorry Mr chairman just to clarify it's
got on the recommendation to review and
note the contents of phase one cross
is the recommendation correct or is it
incorrect
um I'll just go back and have a look at
that
yeah it definitely says in the paper
both papers are for noting no decision
required
members you are voting on this item
please the voters in progress
thank you very much that is seven votes
full that's unanimous thank you
next is item 11 paper BCA 2236 the
Hadley 1871 roadside commercial
workspace development
um and this will be a paper we vote on
definitely
item
12.
excuse me chair I have noticed that you
have given the item various numbers as
you okay yeah that that is because
because the script is wrong the script
is wrong yeah yes I do apologize the
order of the students are wrong
but you get the right script next time
there was there was a gap actually in
the item numbering between
um the minutes and the questions by
councils it went from three to five
anyway
the next item the final item
is paper BCA
2236 that had the 1871 roadside
commercial workspace development
I'll introduce this report
members will remember that we have
already discussed and and voted on the
progress of this project but this paper
is to report back because there are
three effectively three changes that
will need confirmation and approval
firstly we have an updated viability
appraisal on the options and the
borrowing costs
we've also
um got a new
potential buyer for the convenience
store
and Retail unit and therefore we've got
the draft heads of terms for an update
updated Freehold disposal of that
and and finally
um we have uh again
um the draft heads of terms for the
anchor tenants site the office site
now these the details of all of these
are in the appendices a b and c which
are confidential so if anyone wishes to
discuss the um the detail of that we
will have to have a vote to go into
confidential session
however
um the important thing is we're going to
have to make
decisions around this obviously we've
got to know the progress
of the scheme layout which again the
um the final scheme layout is in
appendix d
we've also got to authorize the director
for economic growth and climate change
to conclude the optimal scheme layout
based on the
occupying local intelligence gathered
for this and then proceed to submit a
planning application which will be early
next year
we've also got to prove the draft has
has the terms lease agreement for the
office unit and that's in your
confidential appendix B
and um we've got to delegate to the
director for economic growth and climate
change the authority to agree or vary
any final terms for that lease agreement
and
um finally we have to approve
uh the substituted bid the new bid for
the Freehold transfer of the A1
convenience retail and drive through
space and the details of that are in
appendix C and also to delegate against
the director for economic growth and
climate change the authority to agree or
vary those final terms
and also should it be necessary to
accept a substitute bid should this one
that we have not proceed providing that
substitute bid is on the same or similar
terms
and of course we've got to proceed with
marketing the remaining light industrial
units which will we will be retaining
the ownership of
so that's um the uh the paper which I'm
proposing and I'd like to have a second
to please for this
councilman crawl
can I ask before we go any further is it
going to be possible to discuss this in
any meaningful way without going into a
confidential session I mean it seems to
me that all of those decisions do refer
very obviously to the appendices they do
and I don't think we can so I'd like to
propose that we'd go into a confidential
session so we may give this its proper
consideration thank you would anyone
like to second that castle avici
excellent okay right
um we will then take a vote to
oh I've got to read all of that right
yeah sorry exclusion of the public
um to consider whether pursuant to part
one or schedule 12a of the Local
Government Act 1972 the public should be
excluded from the meeting for the
business specified Below on the grounds
that if the public were present during
this item
it is likely that there would be the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against the item the author
of the report proposed to be considered
in part two of the agenda is satisfied
that the public interest in maintaining
the exemption outweighs the public
interest in disclosing the information
so we've had that proposed and seconded
and maybe now have the vote please
thank you chair that's seven votes for
that unanimous we are now going into
closed session
right okay thank you we're back into
Open Session now
um before we go to the boat is there
anything anyone else wishes to see an
open session about this
all I would like to do is to to sum up
and say that
as before this this is an excellent
opportunity we've been presented with
for Hadley a mixed use commercial site
right on the edge of town on the on the
bypass and I'm really pleased we're in a
position now to take the whole site
forward with um three very different and
and complementary components to it so
um I'm just looking forward to when it
can all get built out and occupied
particularly the small industrial units
because I think they're going to be
incredibly useful for micro and startup
businesses in in the Hadley area because
it is it is a growing town the
population is rising and and uh there
are and it provides an opportunity for
local employment for new businesses
councilman did you want to say something
whether it's probably early days
obviously but whether there's been any
interest shown in those units and yet
yes um so um the marketing agent has had
some inquiries um and the paper does ask
for permission to carry on that um and
just as well to mention that the figures
and the development appraisal does
include all costs agent fees Etc within
and we still do have some um Surplus
left for from the original cabinet
um amount that was allocated for
marketing agent but yes we are getting
interested that will continue if
approved
thank you Lee
right well I've um summarized the
recommendations in my introduction so I
won't read them out again they've been
proposed and seconded
um we'll now move to the vote please
thank you chair the vote has done
progress
that is seven months for that unanimous
chair thank you right that brings
today's meeting to a close and the next
meeting is scheduled for Monday the 9th
of January 2023 at 2PM thank you
everybody